c'est quoi ça temps mais c'est une
météorite
tu fais quoi avec un 9 10 minutes un
cours vous savez que c'est une
obligation légale en fait d'aller à la
police contenant un cadavre sur les bras
t'inquiète pas on va essayer bien s'en
occuper pour passer à autre chose
normalement c'est des chrysanthèmes à un
enterrement alors c'est l'intention qui
compte
pourquoi il peut toujours les lendemains
d'enterrement peut-être pour laver nos
âmes de la déprime et enfin nous
permettre de passer à autre chose si on
veut pas passer à autre chose
jean laisser une trace on passe le rambo
mais comme lénine la plus vieille momie
à 9400 ans pas éternel moi perso je le
chope road cryogénisé hors sas a
approuvé ni par la communauté
scientifique ni par le corps médical
piégé dans l'ombre comme dans jurassic
park ça marche sur les insectes ou les
petits machins mais un truc groeppelin
dos comme nous et écrire un livre
un chef-d'oeuvre comme le code civil
mouais
à mon avis la postérité ultime ce serait
de devenir un fossile en fait à poser
une question à laquelle personne n'a de
réponse juste pour plomber l'ambiance
quoi déjà on a de la chance d'avoir un
squelette ce sera beaucoup plus facile
les autres avancent beaucoup mieux les
âges que les parties molles les chairs
disparaissent au mur on en garde une
empreinte mais c'est ultra rare mais
même malgré ça il faut vraiment des
conditions environnementales très
particulière pour arriver à fossilisé le
mieux c'est le fond d'un lac ou d'une
mer peu profonde comme ça les sédiments
vont nous recouvrer rapidement ça évite
un conte se passe boulotter par les
charognards et 2 qui est trop d'oxygène
à notre contact comme ça ça va ralentir
notre décomposition et ça donne plus de
temps pour fossilisés en paix comme
disait stéphane eicher sinon dans une
tourbière ça marche aussi vu que c'est
un milieu pauvre en oxygène
à partir de là on a deux options dans le
premier pack voyage inoubliable nos
chers se décompose alors que l'eau un
big notre squelette peu à peu les
minéraux transportés par cette eau vont
cristalliser dans les ports de
nouzonville vont nous solidifier tout le
tralala et même le ding ding dong
c'est la paire minéralisation dans le
deuxième pack notre ultime berceau de
sédiments sein du rpt suffisamment pour
faire un moulage de notre corps corps
qui est dégradée qui donc disparaît
alors que d'autres minéraux remplissent
les trous du coup bas ce sera plus
vraiment nous ce sera un moulage à
l'identique
c'est comme ces lapins de pâques en
chocolat tout le monde le sait pas mais
ils ont été moulés sur des vrais
cadavres de bébés lapins et il ajoute la
clochette après et après justement si le
but c'est juste de laisser une trace
comme on fait pipi sur un mur pour
exister pour pas tomber dans l'oubli ou
parce qu'on a la vessie pleine ça a un
intérêt assez limité à mes yeux
pour en profiter pour transmettre des
connaissances tant qu'à faire pour être
l'émissaire de notre civilisation
actuelle à condition qu'une personne du
futur tombe sur nous en guidant ses
carottes 5.0 bon par contre faut même
pas imaginer ans portait une valise là
où va du coup à moins de se graver la
critique de la raison pure sur le tibia
le paléontologue du turf l'ue aura du
mal à reconstituer notre culture là le
paléontologue du tueur fou pourra
essayer de dresser notre portrait robot
en prélevant notre adn si nous en reste
un peu il pourrait essayer de nous
relier à d'éventuelles autres fossiles
et nous replacer dans le grand arbre du
vivant du vivant et du mort du coup en
étudiant la morphologie de notre
squelette il pourrait essayer d'en
déduire si on porte des yeux ou si on
est vivants par si on est bipèdes tripet
de quadrupèdes
si nous auscultent comme un médecin
légiste de l'extrême il pourra essayer
d'en déduire de quoi en est mort et
quand aussi en battant la roche autour
de nous finalement ce qui perdurera nous
c'est parce qu'on possède ce qu'on sait
ce qu'on a appris mais uniquement ceux
qu'on aime un humain bipèdes vivipare
omnivore un peu ce que lieuse et parce
que on a fait trop de personnes se
souviendra qu on a lu la fontaine des
cartes et super picsou géant n'a vu le
sosie officiel de florent pagny en
concert ni même que toutes ces choses on
existe un jour final personne sera que
ce qu'on préfère par dessus tout c'est
l'odeur des pâtes qui cuisent et et le
goût du malaise
pourquoi c'est vrai que si on regarde
dans le passé dans le domaine mais qui
me paraît ce point peut donc dans la
linguistique et linguistiques
historiques notamment ceux du coup j'ai
pas trop parler d'archéologie ou
interpréter ce qui rend les tombes et
c'est clotilde en avait déjà parlé dans
la première saison et linguistiquement
parlant réfection du coup ce qu'on a
c'est des textes et les textes c'est
vachement important pour deux choses
déjà parce que ben ça donne des
informations sur la langue
comment tu écrivais la langue c'est près
sa grammaire c'est quoi les mots clés
utilisés c'est quoi les femmes donc on
permet de reconstituer l'histoire de la
langue est aussi tout simplement vers le
fond du texte c'est à dire de quoi ça
parle et ça donne des informations sur
la société sur les gens sur comment il
veut et sait déjà c'est pas toujours
facile parce que des fois les textes en
plus on les a de manière parcellaire on
n'a pas tout on n'a pas forcément
beaucoup de contexte on peut avoir son
appel d apax un pacs un mot qui
n'apparaît qu'une fois on n'a qu'une
occurrences du mot dans la langue
bah du coup on peut des fois le déduire
par le contexte quand on a des
traductions des fois pas du tout des
fois on sait juste pas du tout ce que ça
veut dire ça fait des textes à trous et
en fait si le truc c'est que avant
l'écriture tu as un peu un espèce
d'angle mort sur ce qui pouvait se
passer parce que tu peux très bien
reconstruire des langues sont le fait
c'est à dire on prend des gens qui sont
relativement proches on arrive à le
reconstruire plus ou moins un stade
antérieur avec des méthodes qu'on
appelle de la méthode la grammaire
comparée
c'est ce que j'ai su ce que j'étudiais
m'a justement le truc c'est que y arrive
quand même à un moment où tu as comme un
angle mort c'est à dire en gros tu
arrives à arriver un peu un stade
antérieur mais tu peux pas tout
reconstruire c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
en plein d'européens qui est
probablement la langue reconstruite la
mieux reconstruite la plus reconstruite
et celles qui nous projette le plus loin
dans le passé c'était il ya 6 ou du
milan ac il ya pas si longtemps que ça
quoi et pareil aussi une question c'est
ben est ce que c'est ce que tu veux
léguer qu'on retrouve et à cette
question je pense qu'on peut dire non
parce qu'il ya bien des trucs genre les
stèles funéraires etc
quoique aujourd'hui je sais pas si les
gens de l'époque quand ils enterraient
leurs morts et pensait qu'on allait les
déterrer les choper les petits morceaux
de textes qui avait dedans pour essayer
de comprendre comment il parlait je
pense que ce n'était pas le délire à
l'époque et aussi tout simplement pas ce
qu'on retrouve ça a pas l'air d'être ce
soir
les gay quoi quand il retrouve un que
machin se plaint que que on lui ait pas
livré la bonne quantité de céréales ou
genre de trucs
et puis à tout simplement aussi des fois
les gens ont beaucoup écrit mais on sait
pas ce qu'ils ont écrit
on comprend pas ce qu'ils ont écrit par
exemple sur l'île de crète où il y avait
l'assignation me noyais nos deuxième
millénaire avant notre ère on a trouvé
des textes qui seront appelés en
linéaire à qu'on en avait deux on avait
linéaire aline rbds et linéaire mais on
a des chiffres et dans les années 50
mais l'inera on l'a toujours pas
déchiffrer on sait toujours pas ce que
ça veut dire c'est même pas dans quelle
langue c'est écrit en a des idées mais
en tout cas on n'y a pas de ne pas de
consensus établi il ya pas de traduction
qui a été fait et même des fois on ne
sait pas si ces langues ou pas par
exemple le disque de faillite aux
secrétaires trouvait aussi sur la ligne
de crête à côté du linéaire a en fait
c'est des disques avec des symboles on
sait pas si c'est du texte ou si c'est
juste un conte qu'à dessiner des deux
seins quoi on peut pas savoir
on sait pas et donc du coup c'est ça
aussi poids et pour finir il ya des
moments où ces vents des trucs très con
qui pour nous sont vraiment fondamentaux
dans linguistique pour la retrouver mais
qui sont vraiment des trucs très
anecdotique du genre la peine dicks
proby c'est une liste de mots en bas
latin ou en latin après le 1er siècle
une liste de mots clés les gens prononcé
mal c'est-à-dire il ya un gars café une
liste des mots il faut pas dire comme ça
pour dire comme ça alors pour nous c'est
très intéressant linguistiquement
parlant ça permet de retracer
l'évolution de la langue mais je pense
que c'est parce que les gens ne
s'étaient pas voulait léguer quoi il
voulait pas léguer une liste de fautes
quoi enfin une liste de ce qui était les
fautes pour les peuples seront pas de
celle des taux de change entre l'euro
quand tu vois que des fauteuils des
civilisations conduire et des centaines
des milliers d'années où il y avait
vraiment une vie avait une écriture y
avait une langue et une société etc
et quand on voit ce qu'on en pense qu'il
nous reste quasiment rien oui ça fout un
peu le som quoi parce que du coup qu'est
ce qu'il va rester nous depuis le début
du 20e siècle des chercheurs songe très
sérieusement à ressusciter des espèces
éteintes comme marc bouter jésus à
pâques et grâce à l'avènement de crise
peurs ses ciseaux génétique
extraordinaire l'opération paraît un peu
plus faisable
je m'explique jusqu'à maintenant la
technique de clonage qu'on utilisait
consistait à transférer le noyau d'une
cellule du donneur dans l'ovule
dénoyautées d'une espèce proches
génétiquement de prier très fort et paf
ça fait un clone parfois c'est comme ça
qu'est née la brebis dolly en 1996
c'était le tout premier mammifère cloné
de l'histoire et d'ailleurs pour
l'anecdote les créateurs de la biquette
leur et baptisé en hommage
à dolly parton une chanteuse de country
américaine à la poitrine généreuse parce
qu'ils avaient utilisé des cellules de
glandes mammaires pour cloner la bête
classe distinguer raffinés ça c'est la
science qu'on aime mais bon cette
méthode n'est pas franchement idéal
puisque les clones sont souvent mal fini
dolly la brebis avait de l'arthrose des
problèmes respiratoires et elle a
vieilli prématurément la pauvresse si
c'est pour revivre dans ces conditions
c'est peut-être pas l'idéal heureusement
une nouvelle technique est apparue il ya
quelques années
alias les ciseaux génétique au départ
c'est une famille de petit bouddha des
haines qui se baladent dans des
bactéries qui ont un super pouvoir s'y
voit passer un virus attaque ils leur
père ils le détruise avant que le virus
ait le temps d'infecter la bactérie
haute ces petits soldats font ça en
détectant et en découpant des séquences
d adn bien précises qui reconnaissent
dans le génome du virus
en voyant ça de biologistes emmanuel
charpentier et jennyfer jeunes se sont
dit attendez voir puisque ça c'est
reconnaître des portions d'adé n est que
celle des coupes un endroit bien précis
ne pourrait pas nous permettre de copier
coller des gènes dans le génome de ce
qu'on veut c'est ainsi qu'elles ont lié
au point les ciseaux génétique crise
perd 4,9 qui permettent de modifier le
génome de plein d'organismes des oiseaux
des insectes des reptiles des mammifères
et oui y compris l'humain ce qui pose
plein de questions d'ordre éthique
surtout depuis qu'un chercheur chinois
s'est amusé en 2018 à fabriquer des
bébés crise peur mais c'est une autre
histoire
bref ces ciseaux génétiques sont
incroyablement précis il ya encore
quelques petits soucis à régler
notamment deux us target c'est à dire
que des fois ils peuvent engendrer des
mutations non désirées dans le génome
c'est plutôt ballot mais ça reste un
outil extrêmement prometteur les
chercheurs améliore constamment cette
famille d'outils donc on peut aller
qu'en s'améliorant toute façon l'impact
est elle sur la discipline qu'on parle
carrément de révolution au printemps
emmanuel charpentier et jennyfer 12 n'a
été listés par le time magazine parmi
les 100 personnes les plus influentes du
monde donc
revenons-en à nos mammouth une fois
qu'on a séquencé le génome du mammouth
et celui de l'éléphant d'asie sont plus
proches parents actuels on pourrait
imaginer utiliser crise peur pour pimpé
le génome du second et le faire
ressembler au premier avec le ciseau on
ouvrira l'adn de l'éléphant comme un
collier de perles on y ajouterait
quelques perles hausse du même ordre que
d'un collier du mammouth et on
recollerait le tous ensemble
c'est exactement ce qu'a fait john
church généticien à l'université de rome
en 2015 il a introduit des gènes de
mammouth dans des cultures cellulaires
de peau d'éléphant
c'était la première fois que ces gènes
de mammouth se retrouvait à nouveau
fonctionnel dans une boîte de pétri
calmez vous mais chuck chat de
l'ambition au sein de son laboratoire le
orvin giuly mahmoud préparez vous il
trie fouille des cellules d'éléphant
pour en obtenir à un genre de cellules
souches de pseudo mammouth enfin de
mamou fin puis il les spécialisant
divers types de cellules par exemple des
globules rouges des poils ou des
cellules graisseuses pour voir si elles
ont bien les caractéristiques qu'on
attend chez un mammouth quand il sera
satisfait il pourra reprendre ces
cellules souches et en faire un embryon
de mamou fait qu'il compte
incubé dans un utérus artificiel ça
c'est la science qu'on aime
bon par contre c'est pas pour demain
certes le génome de l'éléphant d'asie et
celui du mammouth sont similaires à 99
96 % mais il reste quand même 1,4
million de paires loose pardon de
nucléotides qui les sépare ça en fait
des manipulations génétiques ce
qu'envisage church
en tout cas dans un premier temps c'est
plutôt de fabriquer un éléphant qui
supporte le froid en empruntant quelques
traits au mammouth qui est déjà pas mal
mais on est encore loin de ressusciter
le casting de l'âge de glace en suivant
le même principe on pourrait imaginer
bidouille elle génome d'un poulet pour
obtenir un vrai t-rex on passe sur les
séquelles psychologiques de maman poule
et ont imaginé et vous attendre un bébé
en fête surprise vous accouchez tata
jacky qui est morte ya 50 ans mais là on
se heurte encore un autre problème c'est
que pour pouvoir reproduire une peinture
de mètres il nous faut le tableau de
départ si on n'a pas le génome du t-rex
on peut rien faire et à l'heure actuelle
bas on n'a toujours pas trouvé de dn2
t-rex suffisamment bien conserver ces
molécules très fragile qui commence à se
dégrader dès qu'on passe larmes à gauche
du coup ben laden de t-rex pas de clown
pas de clown
pas de clown et ouais on peut
ressusciter 17 fois le chien de barbra
streisand mais pas une seule fois 1 dans
tranchantes mais bon mettons qu'on
arrive à fossilisés notre corps qui
traverse les âges qui reste dessus acda
dn pour pouvoir nous clown et qu'ils
soient retrouvés après avoir une
civilisation qui arrive désormais à
ressusciter des fossiles qu'ils en l
envie aussi accessoirement bon soit il
nous faut un beau petit clown à notre
effigie ligue hors de notre grichka
reste encore à transférer notre
conscience dans cette nouvelle coquille
et là encore bas on n'y est pas du tout
du tout vu qu'on sait même pas vraiment
ce que c'est à la conscience bref là on
est très clairement dans la science
fiction
je crois qu'il va falloir se faire à
l'idée qu'il ya peu de chances que ni
vous ni moi ni mon tennis niveau où on
ne laisse de traces durables sur cette
planète
bonne journée merci d'avoir regardé
cette toute dernière vidéo de cette
saison du vortex
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu et si
vous aimez la mort n'hésitez pas à liker
cette vidéo à vous abonner à la partager
a commenté à nous rejoindre sur le
discorde pour parler des bogdanov et de
plein d'autres choses extrêmement
intéressante c'était pas une météorite
c'était un homme de yoni en plus c'était
même pas ta cousine valentine c'était à
moi je suis vraiment désolé on sait
depuis un moment déjà
ça sent à florence en a pris la décision
de déménager je me suis occupé des
papiers c'est mieux comme ça qu'on nous
ait pas partir comme ça comment on va
faire qu'on va faire pour le loyer
vous savez bien trouver une solution et
merde
elles sont sérieuses ou
[Musique]
et pour bien conclure cette saison du
barça que je vous propose de me
rejoindre
maintenant tout de suite sur tweets il y
aura les en descriptions quelque part
j'y serai là à la diffusion de la vidéo
comme ça on va pouvoir débriefer
ensemble toutes les choses merveilleuses
qui se sont dit
et puis tu vois là si vous avez des
questions sur le fait d'être
insignifiant dans ce monde et de ne pas
laisser de traces après sa mort
n'hésitez pas ça va être bien aller
flâner